[Music]
screenplays follow a certain set of
conventions for example they're
generally between 90 to 120 pages use
black courier final draft font and have
set margins but there's a script they
just read that breaks all of these rules
and it even has pictures in this episode
I want to look at the first draft of
Scott Beck in Brian woods
and how the script made for an
unconventional yet immersive reading
experience keep in mind this is the beck
and woods draft not that Krasinski
rewrite which showed in theaters so
there will be some differences including
names of the characters the first
noticeable difference is that the script
is only 67 pages 22 less than the
recommended minimum of 90 and of these
67 if you take up space with pitchers
unconventional formatting and fonts on
page 28 for example we see a Monopoly
board which acts as a makeshift map
showing where the shed lake valley and
turbine are in relation to one another a
few pages later we see a collection of
pins April the Deaf daughter keeps of
her long-lost sister now in this draft
there's a bunch of flashbacks involving
John and a daughter who died before the
invasion of the monsters which changed
in the Krasinski draft these pins act as
a motif showing up several times in the
script and because we are shown them
visually they're easier to remember
especially when they are vital to the
plot newspaper headlines like the one
here on page 9 or the faded ones on page
26 are written in the font and style
like they would in actual newspapers
they are attempts to draw us in and make
us feel more a part of the world on page
53 the writers go so far as to insert a
visual comparison between a skyscraper
Statue of Liberty and a wind turbine the
wind turbine playing an important role
in this drafts third act where the
characters try to trap the monster
within its hull when John finally traps
the monster his plan backfires when he
realizes the monster can see in the dark
this realization is depicted in the
script when the font changes to white
set against a black backdrop shown here
pictures aside beckon woods format the
pages differently as well in one of the
tenses
scenes where John needs to get back to
his pregnant wife who's giving birth
during a monster attack an entire five
pages is devoted to just 15 words John
is 30 feet away from the shed 20 feet
away ten feet five snap you may have
noticed that even the font gets bigger
as John closes in two pages later the
opposite happens the font gets smaller
quiet and sound is a crucial element to
the story as such the writers underline
almost every bit of sound accentuating
its importance here on page 13 you can
get a sense of what a typical page looks
like but formatting is also used
creatively like here on page 60 when the
word closer is used to denote two
characters coming closer and closer
together there are countless other
examples riddled throughout the script
which I encourage you to check out on
your own but the question remains does
it work and I would say yes but with
caution the creative choices made by the
writers such as pictures and formatting
changes aren't put in just for the fun
of it rather because they fit the story
they have purpose they elevate it but no
amount of pictures or changes can fix a
bad script and this draft although not
as strong as Krasinski's delivers a
unique premise and solid story executed
in a fashion that immerses the reader in
this special world if you haven't seen
the movie or read the script go check it
out and until next time keep on writing
if you like this video please like and
subscribe
the Belon and check out my other videos
below
[Music]